what's going on guys this is rob and
after long
last we finally have the conclusion of
venom marvel's delayed this for like a
month right it was supposed to come out
the same time that the king in black
ended
and then marvel just kept delaying it
over and over and over again
so it was like okay fine and then i was
like we'll just wait and see so this is
the reason why we haven't done
a king in black like a full-on donnie
kate's venom run full story yet because
we were honestly waiting for the story
to end and here's a kicker to this
this beast is 80 pages long it's a
gigantic conclusion to the to the end of
venom so
what this does and we kind of get a
little bit of a cursory glance here not
a whole lot doing the first little bit
that we get is really just kind of venom
running over a lot of what we already
know right which is you know once upon a
time i was a villain and then i was an
anti-hero then i became a hero then i
defeated noel and i got the powers of
god
and now we're here and that's basically
it that's more or less venom's entire
career summed up in the span of of
you know 10 seconds but one of the cool
things to come out of this is remember
noel the symbiote god was the one that
had full control
over all the symbiotes across space and
time with null having been defeated
that passed to eddie brock and so now
eddie brock has total control of all the
symbiotes across space now one of the
things that it kind of hits that here
is that his involvement and not even
really hits that it just kind of
solidifies
his involvement through the universe is
immense right when it comes to the
various superheroes that we see in
marvel comics you look at superhero
teams like the guardians of the galaxy
you look at the avengers and even
individuals captain america different
things like that there's a lot of
limitations there mostly because the
powers they have are not exceedingly
vast
i guess peter quill's powers are right
now like he's basically a god mode
character
but with regards to most everybody else
their powers are not
exceedingly advanced and even when you
look at characters like franklin
richards or the molecule man owen reese
while they are exceedingly powerful
their ability to engage in things that
can kind of fix the universe are
limited to what it is that they're aware
of going on at that point in time now by
and large for cosmic level
reality warping characters uh having a
kind of cosmic awareness sort of goes
hand in hand with that but what eddie
brock is basically doing here
is healing the universe and really
helping a lot of aspects of the universe
so on the planet fallow for example he's
basically helping to rebuild the
empire of this place following null
basically tearing it down and leading to
the ruin of this kingdom
one of the other things this kind of hit
on here which is really really cool is
this talks about a fissure which can
kind of go either way
i would say it's probably the fissure
that was used by null to enter into
space
but as far as i'm aware that fissure
that was open during thanos imperative
that led to like the arrival of the
cancerverse while it was
technically closed i'm pretty sure it
was reopened again and so i think he's
kind of closing it back
off and then of course you also end up
having him meeting with the avengers and
meeting with
with asgard and so on and so forth but
the funny thing about this is
despite all these things that he's doing
eddie brock is not actually there
instead eddie brock is having the venom
or the symbiotes act in his stead that
oftentimes they're taking on the
appearance
of him and then in turn they're just
kind of going through and engaging in
different acts
the other thing about this is that eddie
brock's aged up and he's he's an older
guy now right a little bit of time has
passed here
since the events of the conclusion of
king and black and eddie brock at the
moment and there's two major things
going on
the first is that in his older age it's
very difficult for him to be able to
basically function and control the hive
mind essentially control
the species operating across the
universe and depending on the
circumstance because he kind of talks
about different dimensions and so on
and marvel's been using dimension and
universe interchangeably recently so we
can either say its dimensions inside a
universe or we can say it's other
universes but regardless controlling a
hive of this size
is a very difficult thing for him to do
and so it takes a huge physical toll on
him the other part of that is dylan
is it his teenage years
and it's one of the things that he says
right like the the the just the
difficulty of me focusing on the hive
and trying to control all these
different
symbiotes and so on and having an entire
army at my fingertips and even though i
can see through a billion eyes and touch
a trillion souls
fight infinite wars there's no force
powerful enough in the universe
to control a teenager and that's really
what it is right i mean
that's the thing about teenagers this is
one of these things right teenagers they
they push boundaries they test
limits all that kind of stuff just kind
of the growing process and so
because of that there's kind of a cool
little bit of a conversation that goes
on here
that one of the things that happens is
that the the other right
it's one of the things that eddie refers
to as a symbiote actually transforms
into a kind of animal and accompanies
dylan now this is kind of a two-part
process
the first part of this is because the
other wants to make sure that dylan's
protected and the second part of this
is because of the fact that dylan is
curious and this thing's curious about
dylan they're just trying to kind of get
to know each other better it's just
forming a little bit of a relationship
here which is kind of a cool thing
now one of the other little tidbits that
goes on here and this is an exceedingly
important moment is dylan actually asks
the symbiote what its name is
and that's something that we've never
really gotten before the closest we ever
got to anything like this was when we
learned the name of the actual
symbiote race is called the klyntard but
for this guy we don't really know what
his name is and it's kind of smart for
donnie cades to not really give him a
definitive name because then it's etched
in stone forever
instead the way this plays out is it
kind of tells dylan you can't really
pronounce my name in the human tongue
and the way that we symbiotes work is we
don't really take names instead the way
we identify or differentiate one from
the other
is we latch on to a host and then we
become a reflection of that host's
emotional state which really kind of
begs the question if one symbiote
latches on to like
a psychopath and another symbiote lashes
onto another psychopath are they
basically twins
i don't know how those kinds of things
work but the important thing here is
that that's how they differentiate each
other and so what he actually does
is he kind of allows the sort of
vibrational frequency to impact through
dylan and to actually give dylan his
name which is a touching moment because
it's one of these things where only
dylan would really be able to experience
that and really eddie brock
because of the only ones that can really
resonate with symbiotes in that way
now following that you actually end up
switching over to a kind of luncheon
between uh peter parker and eddie brock
there's a little bit going on here
there's kind of a funny funny thing
going on there's one point where
spider-man asks him like how are you
doing and eddie brock's like
i'm doing good and he's like no captain
america does good you are doing well
kudos donnie kate's that's from 30 rock
so it's one of those little funny things
little funny moments but at the end of
this at the end of the day peter parker
is kind of approaching this from
a little bit of a strange situation and
the reason why is because the power that
eddie has to be able to operate on a
universal scale
that's not one that's quite readily
given to symbiotes and in fact no one
really had that power
until null was introduced and now eddie
brock even when peter parker had the
symbiote it just didn't quite work that
way
the other part of this is that peter
largely attributes everything that's
happened with null
to himself because he kind of looks back
to the original secret wars event that
could be read in 1984
and kind of says if it wasn't for me
this symbiote never would have been
brought back to earth in the first place
now of course the response to eddie is
look man they've been around for a
thousand years man like they fought in
vietnam like
old characters were based on them like
they were here long before you brought
that symbiote back at the time the story
was written in 1984
it was the only symbiote on earth but by
virtue of retcons changing history and
marvel comics we know that they've been
operating on earth for quite some time
so the funny thing is peter's a little
bit pissed off right because eddie's
known this for a long time
and he's kind of like i mean you
couldn't have you couldn't have told me
i've been carrying this weight
on all this time you could have told me
that like it was unnecessary for me to
do it and eddie's like but i'm telling
you now so it's like
you know a small little thing now in the
middle of that where you have eddie who
kind of goes into a trance
right and he essentially has like one of
his other symbiote duplicates kind of
talking to the avengers which we'll jump
to here in a minute somebody runs in the
rod of the place
and as soon as they do right they're
like all right everybody reach for the
ceiling and keep reaching until you
reach it then you see spider-man he's
like oh
come on
[Laughter]
i love the way that donnie gates writes
venom man like this guy's writing
is just spectacular it's one of the best
things and so following that eddie brock
basically takes off by turning himself
into bats right which is kind of a cool
little thing
and then you switch over to the
conversation he's having with the
avengers now
this is stupendously important so the
way this works
is he kind of gives the avengers the run
down over everything right he says like
i can see through the eyes of every
symbiote that has
ever existed not every symbiote that
currently exists but everyone that's
ever existed and he's meeting with
virtually
all the superhero teams right he's
meeting with the avengers he's meeting
with the x-men
in krakowa he's meeting with the the
guardians of the galaxy he's meeting
with all these guys it's one of these
things where he kind of says of all
these different creatures that exist out
there that have ever been bonded to a
symbiote and of all these different
iterations of symbiotes that exist out
there there's only one being out there
who has who has basically escaped me
only one person out there that i cannot
find and he says
the maker now this is when things get
nuts he says you know it's kind of read
from a different dimension
driven insane yada yada and he said
ultimately he ended up traveling back to
what he called
the ultimate universe and he says that's
why i'm coming to all of you because i
believe
that he's coming back because he's in
contact with
the council of reeds yes the council of
reasons back i'm so excited about this
i loved the council of reeds oh my god
but he says basically the whole idea
behind this is to essentially he has to
fix his universe right he has to
basically fix the ultimate universe in
order to be able to officially join the
council of reeds now one of the things
about the ultimate universe is the last
time we saw that prior to its return
was this destruction in the really the
launch of secret wars right the issue
number zero that officially set the
whole secret wars event in motion when
you saw the final incursion between the
main marvel universe and the ultimate
universe
following that the ultimate universe
came back in spider-man 2 by brian
michael bendis
the last story he wrote before he
defected to dc and screwed up superman
and then now we have the ultimate
universe which just kind of been
appearing here and there but we don't
have a whole lot about it we know the
makers from there the maker went back
there it's only appeared a few times in
marvel comics and so because that
what it looks like is happening here is
the the ultimate universe is kind of
like an unstable universe
it exists but it's almost like it's
consistently on the verge of collapse
it's kind of hard to describe because
we're not really given a good
description of it the only real
assumption that eddie brock can come to
is that the only way for the maker to
fix his universe
is to basically replace our universe
with his now exactly what forms this
takes we're not really sure
we have eddie brock talking about things
like invasion and so it may be one of
these things where like the ultimate
universe invades the main marvel
universe and then that's basically it it
just kind of takes over
like me coming in kicking you out of
your house and then moving in myself
that's kind of what this seems like uh
it could be one of these things where
the entire
structure or foundation of the universe
is basically wiped away or at least
taken
and then given to the ultimate universe
to stabilize it which would basically
destroy the main marvel universe in the
process
the important thing to understand here
is that what we're getting
is basically a possibility of the
universe being wiped out
and replaced with the ultimate universe
now i know i know i know you guys are
kind of like i mean come on
you know universal thing again hush it's
one of those things we get to see the
ultimate universe come back i don't want
to hear it i'm excited about it right
like i am i am hyped about it right i
don't want to hear i don't want to hear
no jargon i don't want to hear no
complaining or whining like i'm excited
about this man
this is awesome right i love this idea
of like the ultimate universe returning
and being a credible threat to the maine
marvel universe because the only time it
ever was was during
secret wars captain america extends an
invitation to eddie brock and says hey
man
you've been instrumental in in helping
us basically save the world
and in fact save the universe we want to
officially induct you on the avengers
team now this is
huge this is a big moment because
remember it's earth's mightiest heroes
right not just
earth's most capable people and so
because of that like eddie brock has
been one of these guys where he's
consistently been a villain and this is
kind of donnie kate's just
full on giving us this sort of
conclusion to the redemption story of
eddie brock
eddie brock was this guy who started out
as a villain he had a vendetta against
peter parker he wanted to kill peter
parker over time he and peter had to
work together to face off against
villains like carnage and this led to
eddie brock
basically redeeming himself it led to
him becoming a good guy
this is the conclusion of that he is in
such a position as a good guy now to
where he's being offered a position
among the ranks of the avengers the
problem with this is he says
i could but i'm not going to because the
reality is i
one have much bigger things i need to
focus on and two
you need somebody more capable than me
right in my old age i don't know if i
can hack it man like i'm i'm an
old-timer right i mean i know you're old
cat but like you look young
captain america is younger right and so
he's kind of like okay look i have
somebody else
that can take my place on the avengers
team i have somebody else
that can take my place here and captain
america says who are you thinking home
slice
who you think i'm bringing onto the team
son who do you want to take your place
on the avengers team they better be good
they better be on your level he's like
oh no it's good man
he's like i think you know him and i
think you know him pretty damn well
his name is cactus jack that's not true
i don't know why i said that it's
anti-venom right
it's flash thompson this is cool man
it's it's well really agent anti-venom
now is officially what it's called but
flash thompson is the guy that eddie
brock wants to bring on to the team
in order to officially induct him as an
avenger this is amazing
okay speaking of that we actually switch
over to flash thompson here's a cool
thing
this book is probably just going to be
like a like a springboard for flash
thompson's own comic book series his own
solo series and
if that's what we're getting i'm gonna
tell you right now just based off what
we're seeing here
i'm down right because he basically ends
up going into like this local shop
right and there's this guy taking orders
and some chick making her order and one
of the things he kind of muses about
is that he hasn't really been gone for
all that long but everything already
looks so different right remember the
last time that we saw flash thompson he
was resurrected from the dead
during the king and black story and so
you kind of have this situation where
he's just kind of talking to people and
getting to know people and really just
trying to get himself
back to a place of being comfortable but
it's also pretty easy for him too
because he has no real paper trail as
far as the world's aware he's dead so he
can effectively become
anybody the problem with this is that
while he's talking to this one chick
this bullet comes flying out of nowhere
right and like kills the guy behind the
counter right kills a cashier now at
that point you have what are called
guardsmen who show up now of course
flash thompson turns into his anti-venom
costume right and just starts going to
work on these guys but here's the thing
about the guardsmen right they have
effectively been tasked with hunting
down
symbiotes we don't know exactly who's
doing it right i mean the only thing
that they say is we're guardsmen we're
sanctioned to take out symbiotes or
unauthorized aliens that we track down
so presumably they're probably agents of
like sword maybe they have something to
do with shield maybe they're just like
straight federal agents from some
unidentified intelligence agency it
doesn't really matter but the whole
point about this is that guy that
cashier behind the desk
he's not a human he's a symbiote and
come to find out what had happened here
is following the defeat
of uh of nol the symbiote god not every
single symbiote seemed to go directly
with
eddie brock some of them seem to kind of
either be cut off
or go their own way this one in
particular says he has a had a kind of
terminal illness before his other came
and that he'll be dead in a month
without it right and so it's one of
these these weird little situations but
one of the guys goes to kill him goes to
kill this this kind of symbiote posing
as a human
and and flash thompson jumps in and
basically saves the day
after that because people are aware of
the fact that agent ante venom is back
and they seem to kind of know his
identity because some people got
pictures of his faces
at this point it's just him got it going
forward and trying to figure out what
he's going to do with himself right he
doesn't really know who he's going to be
he doesn't really know
exactly what role he's going to play all
he knows is the king in black
changed everything right it just seemed
to change everything as far as he was
aware if he'd been brought back from the
dead he's got no name he's got no home
he's got no family he's got nothing
right it's just him by himself out there
in the world which is in a lot of ways
the perfect fresh start for somebody
like flash thompson because he can make
a lot out of it and so from there you
switch over to the last little tidbit of
a story here right and this focuses on
dylan and this is one of the coolest
things so of course
you get to midtown high school makes
sense that's where all the great
characters go to school at
and dylan is ultimately being picked on
by a high school bully named
kenny mcfarland jr obviously named after
todd mcfarlane and of course it's one of
these weird things when it comes to
bullies right they're basically just
people who haven't grasped their place
in the bigger picture yet
and dylan has this kind of situation
where he helps this kid to understand it
right this kid's like well you know
i didn't see there you know it's one of
these things where he's like this
hallway's for seniors and and dylan's
like well i mean how many years have you
been a senior right i mean you know
like must be some kind of record right i
mean you know it makes sense get them
while you can right you're not getting
them on the field and
anywhere else from what i can tell right
so dylan starts laying into this kid
right like head
him busts his nose right like like he
gets slammed into a locker then he just
kicks him in the face
ends up knocking him out the window
right outside into the grass right
kenny's all bloody
begging for his life right rapidly
coming to understand his place in the
bigger picture
dylan's just pummeling this kid and then
goes to grab a shard of glass
and then goes to stab him and kill him
only for us to find out that it's just
kind of a hallucination right he's just
imagining it instead he does exactly
what he's been told to do by the school
he's doing what he's been told to do by
his dad which is just
let himself get beat up and that's what
happens right kenny absolutely starts
pummeling this guy now of course
because this is a public school as we
know innocents get punished equally with
the guilty so this is one of those
things where he's kind of taken to the
principal's office and the principal's
like you know we're all kind of worried
about you son like we're worried about
you like you all you seem to be so angry
why are you always so interested in
fighting and the response to dylan is
because i've been fighting my entire
life right that's all i really know
all i really know is facing off against
enemies and fighting different enemies
now it's also kind of a good thing for
him
dealing with conflict is what builds
character it's what teaches you
resilience
otherwise you'll get into the world and
you'll be rife with anxiety and you'll
never know how to cope with anything and
so it's one of these things where as he
as he kind of leaves the school
and just sort of walking around right
with with the symbiote more or less he's
kind of having this conversation with
himself
right and ultimately it's one of these
things where he's experiencing an
existential crisis right because
dylan doesn't know anything about
himself or he doesn't know his place in
this world right all he knows
is he was born and then he was he was
dropped off by his mom
basically to live with his grandfather
who treated him like crap he was rescued
by his dad who he didn't really know
anything about and then almost
immediately after that happened
here comes null trying to conquer the
universe and take dylan with him so all
he's known is struggle and strife he's
never known
a moment's peace now struggle and strife
is how you build character
nobody ever became anybody great by
living in an era of peace
and so because of that dylan ends up
coming across this kind of alleyway
where you basically got jack-o'-lantern
who's just you know just
robbing some chick or something like
that jack o'lantern is a ridiculous
character right like he's never he's
never really been like a serious
character he was kind of cool back in
the day but he's one of these guys where
if you see him in a movie that's how you
know they're scrounging the bottom of
the barrel for characters
but it is a great outing for for dylan
because it's one of these instances
where dylan actually comes face to face
with what it means in some degree to be
an actual superhero in the sense that
the the symbiote basically protects him
and then in turn of course dylan is
injured but in the process the simian
basically snatches him up heals him and
then takes him away
after he's shot by jack o'lantern of
course jack o'lantern's dealt with by
venom in no uncertain terms he
literally just pummels this guy
seemingly beats him to death i don't
know if he actually does kill him but
there's a splatter of blood a scream
you guys know what that usually means
and so following that you end up on a
rooftop where the the symbiote brings
dylan back to eddie brock
and opposed to eddie being upset at
dylan for engaging in superhero
escapades he kind of tells him it was
only ever a matter of time before
something like this happened i didn't
know if your motivation would be to
follow in my footsteps i don't know if
your motivation
would be because you actually want to
make the world a better place i don't
really know what your intention is here
but regardless of what it is you're
looking to kind of graduate out into the
greater tribe so to speak
and to undertake this kind of superhero
role so if that's going to be the case
then understand
it needs to be done in a way to where
you're being safe and you're being
responsible and there's no safer place
in the whole galaxy or even the whole
universe than with this symbiote it'll
give its life
to keep you safe and so that's when you
basically get dylan who dawns the venom
symbiont and effectively becomes the new
venom and what a perfect setting for
this right what a what a perfect way to
kind of end this to sort of conclude the
story of eddie brock and then to have
dylan become the new symbiote the
biggest question that you kind of have
to ask here is how long is this going to
last one of the big issues that you run
into this for
those of you guys who are new to comics
one of the big issues you run into with
stuff like this
is this will be donnie kate's run and
it'll go down as probably the single
greatest venom run in the history of
marvel comics or if not
definitively the greatest venom run in
the history of marvel comics but then
the next writer will come in and the
next writer will decide what they like
and what they don't like and so it could
be one of these things where dylan's
just like hey i'm gonna go see what's
out there and just disappears under the
multiverse and we never see or hear from
him again and eddie brock goes back to
being venom again who really knows right
it's just kind of different writer's
takes on different characters so
again it's cool for what it is and
that's why i think with stories like
this as epic as it is as interesting as
it is you kind of have to look at it in
a bit of a bubble kind of an isolated
chamber and say okay
this will likely change but it's awesome
that we had it so having said that
guys we're gonna bring this to an end
thank you guys for watching the full
story will be out
sometime soon and i will catch you all
later peace